this is screen junkies movie fights
brought to you by nature box now your
host Andy
sigor greetings screen junkies this week
it's getting personal I am so excited
for this one because we have three of
our own here this is going to be the
Backyard Brawl uh three of our producers
uh and staff here have been fighting
non-stop every day while they work here
and we decided to finally put uh put it
on the line for the real
Real Deal fight so this is serious
bragging rights we're fighting for here
today oh yeah and this has been a long
time Brewing behind the scenes for sure
well I want to get to it we we're going
to have some amazing fights today
including who is the next character that
should get their own Lego Movie o That's
creative who is the worst success who is
the worst successful director and what's
the most overrated movie of all time a
lot of fun stuff which you can follow
along on movie fights live # movie
fights live uh on Twitter if you're
watching us live on plus uh but let's
meet these fight Fighters you guys
should know him all if you're here in
the screen junkies Universe uh first up
he's usually in the booth it's JT what
up everybody I got to represent the
Patriots coming off the greatest Super
Bowl victory in the history of NFL Super
Bowls sorry I just had to put that out
there I feel like I have that he's
already really trying to hurt his
chances at the game no listen I I feel
confident enough where that's not going
to hurt me because I could overcome that
and I'm I got that energy Andy the
energy of watching that game with me I'm
at full power all right second he's
usually the one writing the questions
but he didn't get to this week it's Mr
Lon Harris welcome Lon thank you thank
you I'm excited yeah you nervous no no I
mean I it's it's appropriate because I'm
going to deflate all of JT's arguments
so it's a good choice of a t-shirt we
all saw how that ended everybody uh
lastly he's usually on TV fights uh so
excited to have him here in his movie
fights debut Mr Billy business Billy
Patterson welcome good sir thank you and
I I just want to say off off the top uh
cuz everybody's been following us on
Twitter I'm not here today to uh to pull
any mind games I'm not here to you know
do anything to trash my opponents you're
not on the camera I'm not here to uh I'm
not here to I'm here to play the game
I'm not here to uh to do anything uh
crazy I'm here I'm here to do a fair
fight uh and and do this the right way
starting now where did you get the uh
slasher oh it's me it's me it's me me
what shot of JT that is veite jte yeah
that's right that is that's jte when he
found out he would have to lose against
me so spent some money today the best
use of a tax return
ever I uh I want some royalties off that
seriously do you have royalties for this
I want royalties this this is going in
the ration we had invited Carrot Top to
be here he couldn't make it but we like
we put a little prop comedy in the show
oh this is exciting I'm so excited for
this Backyard Brawl this this really is
important for us and they're going to
bring it because there's there's passion
here some our best fights are the ones
where there's a little bit of heat
behind them and there's a there's a
reason for it there will be some today
uh helping us make sure you guys stay on
facto it's our man in charge of the fact
cam Mr Dan Merl how's it I'm doing good
how are you doing I'm doing great wow
Backyard Brawl I'm going to try to keep
track on Twitter Twitter's been a little
uh squiffy this this afternoon but do my
best to keep track TT squiffy okay word
it's squeam squiffy sque sque shy yeah
all right well Dan uh let's do this
helping our you know guys know how to
play this show so I'm not going to tell
you you guys help make this show so you
all know how this works uh so let's get
to it before we do though I have to
thank our sponsor today which is nature
box we love nature box and Dan you have
some Nature Box things over there
correct some salt and LEL potato Cris
zesty nacho curls we got oh these mini
crispy snicker doodles mini Belgian
waffles
Doodles over here see so there you
go JT and I crushed a whole pack of this
mov vanilla animal cookies uh around
shedar and hat chili crackers wow look
at this guys uh Nature Box makes snacks
that are actually taste and better for
you as Dan's showing you the showing off
these items show be my Vana White as I
talked Dan of course uh created with
high quality ingredients and that are
fat uh that are free from artificial
colors flavors or sweeteners so you can
feel great about snacking there are over
100 snacks to choose from that are
delivered right to your door and you can
order as much as you want as often as
you want with no minimum purchase
required and you can cancel it any time
sounds amazing uh so try it out you can
go after the show to
naturebox.com junkies to save 50% off
your first order exclusive to the screen
junkies fans again that's
naturebox.com screenjunkies to save 50%
off your first order thank you eat this
py I have a horse I have a SW horse oh
it's a squiffy pony squiffy pony
delicious thank you nature box for
helping us in the show go support them
please all right let's do this come on
let's get nuts I want to fight you you
want to fight let him fight F stop this
fight I can do this all
day all right round
one this one comes in from James White
the bamp gator uh and he wants to know
uh in honor of the be Lego Batman movie
which I loved
such a great film perhaps one of the
best Batman films yet uh very very well
touching and and Well Done uh we wanted
to ask you guys who's the next character
that should get their own Lego Adventure
uh and we're going to start with you JT
all right this was actually pretty easy
for me um DC is such a huge has such so
many characters and I think it has so
much of that world you could play with
when you go back and play these video
games like these Batman movie came out
of these video games they're huge hits
they' done it with the Hobbit they' done
it with Star Wars Indiana Jones and and
they even touched upon it with Marvel
with the Avengers so I think Spider-Man
is ripe for the he he needs his own Lego
Movie you know why because what I love
about this Batman thing is they don't
mind making fun of the past Batman films
they like to joke around about them even
the 70s Show you know what else had a 70
show Spider-Man and it was horrible you
know what else had some pretty bad
movies in their franchise Spider-Man
there's so many things here you could
poke fun at with the Spider-Man films
that I think it would just be it would
just add so much to the humor and Marvel
is huge right now it's one of the
biggest properties hands down and no one
has yet to really make fun of it no one
has yet to just kind of you know do a
parody so I feel like Spider-Man is the
perfect way to do it because you're seen
it from a kid's angle you have High
School drama there you got superheroes
Iron Man showing up I just think it's a
home run a lot so I'm going a little bit
differently I went with uh Roger Rabbit
and here's uh here's my
argument rude uh you already have Roger
Rabbit in that world combining the
worlds of traditional cell animation and
live action now we're adding a third
kind of Animation it's a whole new world
that they could go to if you will uh of
the sort of Lego town so now you've got
you know the ability to go to Toontown
Lego town and reality and constantly
combine all of those sort of elements
into one it's already the Roger Rabbit
world is already a setup for a ton of
popular cameos people stopping by sort
of this old Hollywood world so now
you've got adding on the Lego world and
all the dimensions of Lego characters
that you can add so those rights open up
this whole new sort of world that you
can add Plus you've already got a great
interesting Lego setting the world of 7s
LA Noir you get to do exactly for The
Lego Movie what you did for Toontown
which is recreate this whole new version
of it what was the Lego world you know
we sort of saw a perspective of The Lego
Movie sort of that's what the Lego world
is like present day this would be a
chance to do like a period throwback
Lego world like what was that City like
in the 70s what would the Roger Rabbit
sort of equivalent Toontown be for the
world of Legos all right Billy all right
so I think why the Lego form formula
works is that it takes something that
maybe takes itself a little too
seriously but is also broad enough that
it has multiple generations of fans so I
think right now especially in the
climate that we're in with Star Wars and
the Resurgence the most obvious
no-brainer choice is to do Darth Vader
because Darth Vader is such a beloved
character by so many people but guess
what he was pretty intense in Rogue one
and I don't know if I want to take my
kid to see that just like a Batman movie
you know I don't know if I want to take
my kid to see that but if it's Darth
Vader in Lego form first of all the kids
are going to love it and the parents are
going to love it and it's also so ready
to make fun of so many dumb things about
the prequels we already know that
there's tons of jokes that they can wink
to we already know that people love Lego
Star Wars Darth Vader is the Clear
Choice on this one all right f it out
guys well I mean the the first thing I
comment about Darth Vader like the whole
point of a lot of these Lego movies is
you kind of take these classic
properties and here's like sort of a
parody here's sort of play on it when
you combine humor and Darth Vader that's
when everything goes wrong that's when
people get upset the jokes are what
people hate they want it to be scary and
intense and you're taking the exact
format that doesn't allow him to be
scary and int this this is for the kids
this is this is not for the adult that
like oh I hope you don't choke on your
aspiration like you're sitting up a
whole movie that that's that is within
the context of a overly serious film of
course I don't want Darth Vader doing
Freddy krer one lers
Dar making Jes because I know what I'm
getting into do I want Batman going
around making stupid jokes in a more
diverse
character Batman's been funny Batman was
on that 60 show that's really cartoony
he's malleable Darth Vader is one guy he
is absolutely not one guy they've
already shown in that Anakin we should
do Anakin Skywalker we need more we need
more Anakin Skywalker movies this is how
you make Dar this is how you acknowledge
the mistakes of the past in a fun way
but you also make Darth Vader accessible
to Young kowledge the mistakes it's
supposed to be a fun movie you're not
supposed to be acknowledg because if
you're a kid you're not going to sit
there and you're not going
to as a parent that has to sit there
yeah let me knock down both your guys
picks because there's so many problems
number one Star Wars has been spoofed
about just about everybody go online
look up Star Wars spoofy you'll find
something make fun of the prequels The
Originals family guys done it space
Ball's done it uh they already do it in
like so many cartoons it it's just it's
been done and if I want to if I want
watch a spoof of the prequels I'll watch
the prequels they're funny without
having me have to make jokes about it
you can just sit around with friends and
watch me like oh this is so stupid I
don't see how that's going to translate
to a Lego Universe there's not it's
already translated to a Lego Universe
there are there are Lego shows already
the the the property is proven no it's
you want to watch toys something that
looks like toys make fun of Star Wars go
ahead and watch do you know what a Raz
is the simplest answer is the right one
Darth Vader makes sense because you
already know that this work I don't want
a Vader movie I don't want Vader he
would be great as a side character if
you picked another character then like
Vader popped up once a while that'd be
hilarious for Vader to be just the whole
time making jokes like I don't
understand how he is the main character
of that movie let me talk about Roger
Rabbit what what kid wants a 70s nor
film I can't wait to get the Bob Hoskins
action figure Bob Hoskins wouldn't be in
it because he in the 70s he was in the
40s also he's dead wa then first of all
the best thing about Roger Rabbit was in
the 40s about Lego the best thing about
Roger Rabbit is novelty the fact that
you're seeing live action with handdraw
animation you still are so now you're
adding a different kind of Animation
you're still seeing
that Roger Rabbit is too far removed
like if at this point I'd rather just
see a Roger Rabbit sequel I don't think
anyone's clamoring said you want to see
my movie see a direct sequel I don't
need to see I don't need to see Roger
Rabbit Lego I I just it's
already you don't need to go the Lego
route the Lego route works best when
it's a property that needs the Lego Tre
I don't even
resp I got to talk about Spider-Man you
absolutely have to
respond stupid Choice there hasn't been
a parody about Marvel and like we just
had Deadpool we just had a movie that
existed only to parody superhero movies
only to parody origin stories and and
you you said it yourself we've had so
many Spider-Man stories so many origin
stories so many takes on the character
do we really need another one just Chang
the format a little bit tell Deadpool is
a rated R movie Taken on the comic book
genre you said never been a parody Take
on MCU M like there just was was a huge
we're talking specifically Marvel and
what they're doing with the MCU that was
not what comic book uh series I think
you guys are missing the point of what
makes these Lego movies great it's
seeing them later it's seeing something
that's taken in a completely different
context Spider-Man is already fun it's
already whal what are you going to see
new in a Spider-Man Lego Han Lector cuz
then it's different like it does not
necessarily who's talking about H your
whole point is oh you have to combine
Lego with something really serious for
it to
work you choose something that has a
wide enough range like a Batman like
Darth Vader where Star Wars can apply to
a full has like Noir detective
side guys guys the question is what
character you don't need to know where
the word character deserves I got to
talk about more Spider-Man super have
already been G to death in
try Star Wars has so many SPS he does
not need that there's so many Star Wars
films out there that literally you want
to see Space Balls Like I said Family
Guy has torn it apart every weekly basis
show hows are there out there there's
tons of Batman gets spoed anywhere
in uh I remember one of my favorite
things as a kid was the Alvin and the
Chipmunk SP is that is that where we're
grading it at oh that thing really hit
the
mainstream in general are teed all the
time to say that it's not worthy because
there are other can you show your kids
Spaceball cuz there's some [__] in there
that you can't show I watched it as a
kid and I loved it well that's why you
are the way you are
J wrong with that oh I mean I just we
we've seen so many Spider-Man stories
we've seen so many Superman stories and
even the context the setting of
Spider-Man is you're in a big city like
a metropolis you know New York downtown
it's exactly what we saw in The Lego
Movie there's nothing new there it would
literally look Gotham is at least a
different location like The Lego Movie
opens in a city that's supposed to look
exactly like Manhattan like what more is
there to do it's just Spider-Man
swinging between the buildings otherwise
it would look identical there's really
like nothing much to add that we've seen
every element of a Spider-Man and and
Spider-Man even is already a funny
character so he's already quipping he's
already making jokes no but it's just
more of the same just another version of
that the only difference would be he's
made of Lego bricks instead of Toby
Maguire this time it's deserving what
deserves to be in that format you guys
have chosen things that are already in a
legoes format in terms of tone Darth
Vader is not within Star Wars isie what
deserves a movie not what deserves to
have a Lego Product place over what
character deserves to have the Lego
treatment you guys chose things that are
already very
Whimsical look at oh my God the scene
with Darth Vader tearing people apical
is your point I'm saying that you chose
things you want you want to walk that
back maybe no I don't want to watch that
back at all let
the God all right all right I let
letting you hopefully get it all out so
we I can listen clearer I'm going to go
back you one more Tire each other trying
to sorry I'm sure my God I was trying to
see if they Tire themselves out I'm
going to go across one more time got why
is yours more deserving than the other
two concise no interruptions we're
starting back with you JT mine deserves
it because MCU right now is bigger than
ever it is the one property that every
person who goes in from a kid to adult
want to see and it's right for the
picking there's not really been anything
that really parried it say Deadpool but
how many kids you take and see Deadpool
none because it's a hard radar movie
it's doing the genre I'm talking about
specifically MCU one of the funnest
things about going to see these Lego
movies is all the cameos Batman Lego
movie all these different characters
come around you have Iron Man the Hulk
there's so many fun things you can do
with all these characters and you can
cast celebrities that aren't playing
them in the movies just like they're
doing in the Lego bat movie they get all
these great comedic actors to fill in
these I roles that already been
established in MCU I think Roger Rabbit
is ridiculous no one's calling for that
that movie was a good 80s film and in my
opinion it's a decent film but doesn't
stand up today I Revisited actually the
very end of last year it's not bad but
again the hoskin's character is
literally investigating like adultery
murder that movie is freaking scary and
I think there's no world there to play
with I mean who are you going to have
Betty Boop and Dumbo that's not
interesting to me as much as like the
Marvel characters you don't have a world
these Lego movies are about a fun world
where you have cameos from other famous
properties and MCU is full of them and
not to mention with Spider-Man you get
the high school angle you got a kid's
eye view of the MCU which we haven't
really seen yet because Tom holl's film
hasn't come out it's not going to be
dark and Judy and you can make fun of
the original Star Wars imagine every
time the guy cries it's like a to
Maguire drawn face or something you
could have a scene where he reenacts the
whole Spider-Man you said Star Wars oh
Spider-Man sorry you could you could
make fun of the fact that toy McGuire
did that whole dance and the Jazz Club
there's so many nods you can make to
these films that will be really funny in
Lego form and that you could actually
just be it's so rip for the picking I
can't imagine they're not going to do
one okay Lon your closings uh I mean I
think all the things that you just heard
about how great the cameos could be work
doubly for mine because they're not
limited to just marvel it's literally
anyone you could imagine being in the
context of Lego or animation could be a
cameo in this so I'm just going to take
that and say it applies better to mine
but this is it's it's such a world if
the argument is that Roger Rabbit
doesn't have a world of course it has a
world it actually has a land at
Disneyland model after it because it has
defined its own world so well the world
of Toontown and all I'm saying is you
already have this establishment of the
world of Toontown now here's an
opportunity to add another world Lego
Town that's right next to Toontown it's
a totally additional world that you get
to
create Legos no they're leg it's just
like the animation of The Lego Movie
sorry what's the difference between Lego
and Lego town because Toontown is sell
animation it looks exactly like Looney
that's what I'm asking so there's actual
animated cartoons a Looney Tunes
so Roger Rabbit is hand drawn Roger
rabbits yeah there's it's all three
there's there's Los a Lego Roger Rabbit
no there's Los Angeles there's Toontown
where Roger Rabbit and Daffy Duck and
Donald Roger Rabbit in Lego form I mean
I think you mix and match like when
Roger Rabbit goes into Lego town maybe
he becomes Lego it's all what you want
to do with the creativity but my
original idea is yeah Roger Rabbit lives
in the Roger Rabbit 2D world then
there's a Lego animation world where EMT
and wild style and Gandalf and any other
Lego characters you want live there and
then there's a human world where people
live and they're alling together
Logistics it's not complicated at all
with the Spider-Man jte you with your
pitch of what Spider-Man would be you
just pitched what is already coming out
in just a couple of days and Spider-Man
is a character that is already like you
said he's already joking with villains
he's already doing all of this stuff
that I feel like a Lego format would
give him otherwise you don't need it LW
I don't know what you just tried to
pitch right there it makes no sense when
you say it it made no sense when I saw
it Roger Rabbit is already in a
Fantastical cartoon world though he's
not going to benefit anymore from a Lego
Movie and no kid wants to see 70s more
no kid cares about who frame Roger
Rabbit with Star Wars with Darth Vader
the great thing about Star Wars just
like Batman is that it appeals to a wide
range of people because of different
outlets and different expressions of the
character we just got a super Kick-Ass
dark Darth Vader and now it's time to
have a Darth Vader that can also appeal
to the super young that's what Star Wars
does best we already know Star Wars
Legos works because it's already a hit
in other formats if I don't get this
point I guarantee you this movie is
still going to get made pointing I heard
you're pointing as Roger what was your
point against my point against jte was
that Spider-Man is already he's already
quipping he's already doing all the Lego
s characters and the movie that he
pitched with all the cameos and
exploring the world we're already
getting that movie in a couple days with
Batman uh Lego Batman that's not a movie
that we're going to want it's going to
come off as a bad ripoff I don't have a
bell it's Marvel's version Oh I don't
have a bell either get our Bells we'll
Bells uh ding ding ding um uh Dan yes as
you're doing the bells Max will
awkwardly walk by you uh and go ahead uh
Spider-Man and Darth Vader are currently
licensed by Lego as figures or sets they
neither one of them have appeared in
film form in either of the Lego movies
there is a Roger Rabbit ride at
Disneyland but it's called Mickey's
Toontown so it's not quite like styled
after Roger Rabbit it's toown it's
Mickey's to Mickey is
there physically present it's called
Micky
Toontown you arguing with Disney you
can't win that a lot of people throwing
some stuff around I'm looking at Lego
Willy Wonka I'm looking at Lego Danger
Mouse Coro Williams says Lego Matrix mik
sparza said Lego Deadpool would be a
seamless transition at rival tag I could
get on board with Lego Back to future uh
James At That B Gator who asked this
question weigh in he says thanks Andy
signore I say Superman DC can't get that
right and needs a lighter tone I saw a
lot of support for Lego Superman also on
Twitter so uh and for everybody who said
that last week's fight was too late
that you're welcome Feast let's not talk
about it last week yeah uh all right
based on the
arguments uh yeah Lon I love you but
what the hell were you talking about
about the question says Lego treatment
then you're like he's 2D whatever I
think I don't it didn't make it didn't I
think all three of us had trouble
arguing but good I I love Roger Rabbit
unlike the others said uh but then I
think Billy did help really sort of
reaffirm it already has that Fantastical
world and we already get that in the
movies why I it didn't make and then
when you it didn't really make much
sense uh so sadly you're out uh so they
end game between Spider-Man and Darth
Vader um and yeah sper you made a lot of
good points about the cameos but that's
sort of and then did talk about the high
school angle and some of the stuff um
but I think uh Billy made a better
argument as to what to Mine from Star
Wars and that we haven't really seen it
and you definitely swon me over when you
sort of reaffirm like the Batman Lego
movie is sort of what you're already
pitching which we get Darth Darth Vader
and Star Wars would be a new take on
things that I think we could see an
interesting angle so Billy gets the
first point well fought well F Twitter
agrees with you Andy 48% of Voters voted
for Darth Vader 36% backing Spider-Man
and 16% voting for that's rer rabbit
Roger Rabbit's tough ham the hammer and
the he has a bell looking for the hammer
too thank you sorry uh no no the hammer
should be back with the Bell isn't it
back there in the Bell oh I see I'm
looking at it I'm looking right at itell
here I'll I'll I'll grab Sor thank you I
got to have my my hammer handly all
right question number round
two uh this is a fun one who is the
worst successful director and W I just
called it I W it um thank you guys uh
who's the worst successful director uh
is the question that that that means
that we we off behind the scenes yes
it's in there they had to have at least
two hit movies to sort of be deemed a
successful director uh who is the worst
out of anyone who's had success who was
the worst working director uh we're
going to you first Lon so uh I went with
uh Mark Forester and and I think what
bothers me so much about Mark Forester
is he takes on such a diverse range of
different kinds of projects and he read
Enders them all terrible it's like they
all pass through this like mediocracy
mediocrity Bland filter before they come
out and the worst of it is when he tries
to take on these really like ambitious
projects like World War Z or Finding
Neverland the or Stranger Than Fiction
and and it just it's fake art he's such
a poser and there's no depth to it
there's no characters in these films
that you care about there's no Humanity
to these films they're just kind of
going through the motions taking the
Styles and genres that other people have
developed and then rendering them as
kind of this like empty Bland output
I'll take a few quick examples monsters
ball which is like an imitation Sundance
movie like let's throw a lot of
melodrama let's put a lot of hysterics
at it let's put good actors in there but
it's just totally empty it's just like
let's throw trauma at you throw tragedy
at you until you just get worn down the
next one I want to take is Quan masal is
quite possibly the worst James Bond
movie we've ever had and coming off of
the high of Casino Royale it's just is
totally forgettable like he's trying to
do the Paul Green Grass like quick cut
thing it makes no sense it's completely
incoherent and then finally World War Z
Globe Trav Brad Pit killing zombie
should be such an automatic home run
such an easy obvious thing and he just
biffs it so bad they can't even get a
sequel going after all this time because
it was so terrible just falls apart and
there you just don't care there's no
through line to it it's just empty empty
style and effects uh there's just
there's just nothing behind it it's just
these are these are fake movies fake art
I hate Mark Forester that was clear
Billy I think uh clearly when you talk
about this guy it's style over substance
and it's it's Zack Snider look Zack
Snider missed his calling in life
cinematographer absolutely would knock
it out of the park Zack Snyder is I'm
pretty sure physically incapable of
telling a cohesive story he someday will
have his own Wing in the Razzy Hall of
Fame this guy is everything he touches
turns to death it's it's Zack
Snider wow okay he's not needing as much
time let's see yeah let me tell you I
went with MC G and because all his films
make profit and that's why he keeps
making movies the problem is all his
movies are pretty much horrible he came
from that this is what happens in
Hollywood when you're a music video
director two things happen you're either
Dave Fincher or you're more Michael Bay
he wish he was close to either of these
guys cuz when you watch it his movies
aren't really they don't tell stories
they're just slick shots to music watch
the first Charlie Angels again it's a
music video it's a music video with some
wire food added into to distract you
from the other music video that's about
to come up and Zack Snider yes
cinematographer the guy could shoot
action so well mck G wishes he had one
tenth of talent Zack Snyder I mean say
what you all direct yeah he 300 300's a
great movie I think Zack Snider is a
great director if you give him the right
material Mick G has not he was given
Terminator salvation and that movie is
an Abomination it's almost unwatchable
he had Christian Bale who was coming off
some of his best work from dark KN and
all that stuff and he made him look
horrible he was he was boring there's
nothing good MC G has done his last film
3 Days to Kill horrible the only film of
his that's not in the that's not like in
the rotten for sure is the first child
angels and I think it's at like 66% so
it barely made it and that's because you
had actresses who they're personable
they're fun the movie is like fast food
it's you watch it once you're like
that's a fun time but there's no
substance no there's no artistic there's
nothing artistic about his movies
they're literally just products and
that's why I think he's the worst
director who again makes profit every
time he makes a movie he makes a profit
no they're not the biggest hits It's not
300 but he's also not making Sucker
Punch to the point where it's like I
have this much money and it just goes to
complete crap j i I got to respond first
of all you're saying the material that
Zack SNY has given is is why he can't
are you kidding me he was given Batman
versus Superman that is the biggest like
soft ball that you could throw somebody
how do you get that wrong had a hor he
got Watchmen which is considered one of
the greatest comic books of all time you
know what his Watchman movie is his
Watchman movie is like a book report and
you read it and you realize Zack Snider
didn't read the book he read the
Wikipedia summary cuz he misses every
single thing that Watchman is supposed
to be G there's not one movie of his
that even comes close to being as good
as Watchmen Watchmen is at least has
some great ideas and he took on a
material that so hard to make and film a
lot of people said that thing was
unfilmable and he is that's the guy you
want doing it sucker punch I'll take
watch over pun
terrible that it blows my mind that some
Sucker Punch that that a Warner Brothers
Executives could sit through with the
entire Sucker Punch movie and the lights
come up they go that's our guy that's
who I want to push what he's us answer
the question is there any MCG film
that's worse than uh Watchmen I mean
better than Watchmen of course we are
Marshall oh We Are Marshall yeah which
is at like 30% and like basically Comm
the first Char angel angel totally solid
movie it's not a classic but it's fun
and it is stylish and I like to point
out that both of these guys called their
directors style over substance whereas I
am not conceding that Mark Forester has
a good style either so on that
level zero style or your director did
Finding Neverland he did Monsters ball
these are Oscar
movies World War Z is a hit because it
was actually entertaining film it's not
oh ow come on it's garbage and you know
it it's at that one shot of like oh they
build a wall out of once you seen that
it's there's nothing what's a memorable
scene in World War Z the airplane scene
is one of the best zombie scenes I've
ever seen what a genius idea to have
zombies on a plane where you come on
it's been down a million times zombies
in an enclose there's a whole movie
trained to boost on after World War Z
World War Z should have been a way
bigger disaster than it was but the fact
that they were able to pull off that
third act all right I get it boat and
waves to his family that's pulling it
off there is no third act it just ends
the whole CBC yeah the CDC at least Mark
Foster has some interesting ideas
stranger fic he doesn't he really
doesn't stranger and fiction with Will
Farah his idea he was a director he
directed the movie that's a hard movie
to put together I but I'm saying he was
able to take that idea it's not a hard
movie to put together and it doesn't
work at all he was able to take the idea
last you heard somebody talk about how
great Stranger Than Fiction is I'm not
saying it's great mov so self-important
it's so ponderous say it's a great movie
it's an okay movie I don't have one okay
movie except for his very first film
Charli Angels then when he finally got
chance to make Marshall is a totally f
when he got a chance to make a better
version of char Angels he did Full
Throttle and it was horrible JT the
other thing that you're you're saying
Terminator Salvation let's be let's be
really clear Terminator was dead when he
got it he just did the double
down already got there that's not like
it's not like no no no no it's not like
MCG got there and it's like oh my God
what did he do to Terminator this Zack
Snider he came to the DC Universe we
like oh my God what did he do to this
Terminator was already Dead on Arrival
MC G was given a chance to rebrute the
franchise he had Christian Bale one of
the biggest stars in the world at that
time and was given a huge budget and he
delivered something that made double
almost what it cost but was still a
piece of crap and everyone hated it you
guys hardly made any movies and like
half of them are above average your guys
made a lot of good movies
like good movies Dawn of the Dead is
good Dawn of the Dead remake is good da
of the Dead remake is good I love like
it's a good movie my director hasn't
made any good movies but oh my God
Finding Neverland and monsters
ball the great Finding Neverland oh how
how we rewatch Finding Neverland all the
time it was when Johnny dip H that point
of like we're all sick of Johnny dip the
only reason that people went and saw 300
was because visually it was
stunning exactly but
he you guys have some bad movies in your
repertoire nobody is arguing that both
your directors haven't made some bad
movies my guy is the worst he has made
the worst movies Batman versus Superman
the only one heard enough Dan yeah uh I
got some l l opinion the mark fer is a
Bad director is a personal one I I
cannot say the facts back that up fting
Neverland was a best picture nominee
monsters ball one Halle Berry and Oscar
for best actress he has uh three rotten
movies the majority fresh movies as far
as the reviews go GT was correct MCG has
one fresh movie which is the original
Charlie's Angels at 68% uh on Twitter um
first of all Twitter's having a
collective meltdown because no one
picked Michael Bay oh a lot
ofad had one movie close to the Rock I
would to pick M like Armageddon is like
pretty good Chris Akens says Roland Emer
but love id4 but the rest are painful
Ben Gard I do like George Lucas but as a
director he's pretty terrible besides
two movies George Lucas that's offensive
like graffiti is good georgec yeah but
but mainly a lot of people very shocked
and surprised that Michael Bay was I
don't think he's the wor abely no I
think The Rock has saved and bad boys
Sav him one interesting choice that a
few people picked were Dennis Dugan
Dennis Dugan is the guy thought about
that but it also seemed like lwh hanging
he's he's all that's a Sandler train uh
all right anything else uh no that's it
it's just uh I'm I'm kind of laon has a
personal grudge against Mar I really
hate Mar I got to be honest I don't yeah
I mean it's not about evidence like oh
he did this on the razis like who cares
who won but I think they sadly L I did
think they gave you enough reasons as to
why your films aren't they just repeated
that they're good they mentioned the
third act in World War Z and all that it
wasn't a train wreck I agree with them
that impressive that they were able to
even released that movie as they pointed
out it was surprisingly more
entertaining than I thought it would be
uh fine Neverland it is a Oscar nominee
yeah it's fine it's on Broadway right
now ringing ringing no but anyway my
point being it's not the
worst R over your
dog there's a lot of good stuff about
monsters as well so anyway I think uh
sadly I just didn't hear enough to s
from your opinion that that was Mark for
so and sadly sadly you're out so it came
between Zack Snider and MC G and I just
think uh I think JT was just really on
his game in this one had just a lot more
punches back to sort of hit because even
even the fact that he could be a good
cinematographer in some of the wins you
were admitting
um I just think you guys even having
trouble naming good m g movies and the
fact that we are Marshall is rotten and
it really is just Charlie's Angels which
is like I got it based on everything
that was heard it was a pretty clear fun
for me for jte uh Dan what did the poll
say the poll was uh pretty decisive 53%
voted for Zack Snider 34% supporting
13% share law hatred
forer there you all right well we're
still in this let's do it round a really
intelligent like 13% segment of the
audience that's voting right every time
yeah Lon you're right I hate that guy he
ran over my dog tooly good job guys uh
all right if you could cancel any
upcoming or potential sequel right now
anyone on the deck what would it be and
we're gon to start with you Billy all
right so hear me out guys uh I think if
I if I were well when you hear this it's
going to make perfect sense I think get
the point I think the first thing that I
would do is cancel Ant-Man and wasp
here's the reason why if I were to say
to you this is a Marvel movie with a
snarky guy in a cool suit and a business
tycoon has a similar suit uh and their
fight am I talking about Iron Man or am
I talking about Ant-Man uh Ant-Man is
what happens when you have a Dollar Tree
version of Iron Man it's one of the
least grossing outof thegate Marvel
movies in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
He's Just Not That interesting he works
better as a Hulk character and and the
thing that really a Hulk character you
like how a Hulk only shows up in in
other people's group movies and the
thing that this movie really has going
against it is that it is sandwiched in
between two of the most anticipated
Marvel movies of all time which is
infinity war and part two or whatever
they're going to end up calling it so I
walk out of the theater like oh my God
this was the biggest Marvel movie of all
time what a boner killer to then have to
go to the most inconsequential character
that you have in the entire Marvel
Universe I say you scrap Ant-Man he
works great with the group but that
movie is just not going to be what
you're going to want to see is this in
between Infinity Wars can you confirm
that for me Dan I will confirm that yes
go ahead JT uh I'm going with a movie
that people it's the worst case of
nostalgia sequels I think out there I'm
going with Space Jam 2 cuz the first
movie is actually God awful I'm sorry if
you're out there and you like Space Jam
go back and watch it as an adult it's
horrible it's a giant product placement
I mean I could just sit here with a
laptop and play the last honest trailer
we did for Space Jam and it would make
my argument for me the fact that you got
LeBron James who to me listen there's
not enough proof to say he's could carry
a movie okay he did a little scene in
train wreck and he was fine but did kind
of look like he was reading his lines
right before he said them like off
camera he doesn't have like Charisma
he's a basketball player in Looney Tunes
who here still watches Looney Tunes kids
are not aware of Looney Tunes bug's
bunny is not selling out action figures
that toys right now there's no Looney
tun video games it's just like a dead
property that your parents like but kids
today just don't connect with so for me
you're taking a guy who can't act to a
sequel to the movie that's really bad
and is just literally there to make
money and you're taking a a product that
to me is just dead if you're going to
revive Looney Tunes don't do it Space
Jam 2 do it with an actually brand new
CGI Pixar style anything maybe a new 2D
animation we haven't got enough of those
today actually build your Looney Tunes
Universe back up up before you just go
right into Spider-Man where it's just
going to be just like the first movie a
bunch of references to movies just just
like the first one they reference Pulp
Fiction they reference anything that's
hot at the time and it's just cheap and
it doesn't last the test of time the
reason why Space Jam is bad when you go
back to watch it it doesn't last all the
jokes land flat because they're of the
time they're not something that's going
to last throughout the eons of
Cinema L all right uh I think I think uh
there's one franchise that everybody
sort of realizes like it it's stuck and
we don't we don't want to keep going in
the way that it's been going it's die
hard so I'm picking die hard year one
which is actually their pitch for how to
keep going with Die Hard which would be
like prealize it it's like before the
events of the first movie This Not only
is it continuing with the same trend of
like let's just make bigger more
explosive Die Hard movies it actually
actively undermines the series because
the whole thing that's great about that
first Die Hard is that mlan is like a
regular guy he's not a superhero in the
first movie so if you do a prequel in
the new style where it's super overblown
alone he's like a super he's he's you
know Dom from Fast and Furious jumping
over helicopters and cars you're ruining
then how it links up to the first movie
which is this regular New York cop stuck
in this crazy uh situation that that he
doesn't know how to deal with like if
you want to figure out what to do with
the Die Hard series I think it's like
total reboot don't recast mlan but come
up with other characters other scenarios
trying to go back and do a mlan prequel
it's just really painful it's going to
like it it undermines the character that
they've spent so long now to find
uh and setting up all right guys uh
first of all let me just go ahead and
start with uh I mean I'll touch on anman
briefly for me I hope it's between the
infinity Wars because to me Ant-Man was
this great thing from Marvel that was a
little different it was a comedy it was
a heist film it was that but it didn't
do either of those very well they
chickened out on that heist in the third
act and went just like let's just do
this the same old Marvel way that the
team you brought in with Michael Pena
like I really enjoyed having that
interaction with that team Michael
Douglas was great also for me I just
think Paul Rudd is perfect in that role
like it's it's just perfect it adds a
different spice to the Marvel yeah he is
perfect but he also is so works so much
more effectively in Civil War in small
doses when you get too much of him
inconsequential only because he had that
film beforehand and Payton Reed came out
on that project and it was a mess
because Edgar right left and he still
made a good film because he loved the
character the reason why I want a wasp
film with Ant-Man is because now Payton
Reed somebody who grew up loving Ant-Man
for the first could start from day one
with the mid and it's a team up it gives
him somebody to work of it's not just a
solo just coming off the biggest team up
maybe in cinematic history it's
obviously not a team up on the fact the
fact that this is coming after infinity
War you've already told me that the
stakes aren't as big because how could
it if there's another part to this big
huge story has to ratchet up the same
Stakes it could be diver it's a huge
franchise already it's already by
default less interesting already
interested in it because marel already
announced that's not part one and part
two anymore they're both going to be
standies so it's not going to be like to
be continued and oh by the way Antman
went and did this Heist that's not how
it's going to work it's one of the very
few superhero movies we coming up that
has a central female hero in it if we
cut it you're just cutting more you
gotal female Heroes coming out you have
Captain
Marvel what about that uh we we talk
about Looney Tunes are still on Cartoon
Network literally every day in the
afternoon so kids absolutely still know
and still care about Looney tun
ridiculous to be like oh they don't care
anymore and they did try to reboot
Looney Tunes without doing a Space Jam
movie it was called Looney Tunes back in
Action and nobody saw it so if they want
to bring Looney Tunes back Space Jam is
the perfect property to do it and it's
totally kids like it it'll be fun again
and the new movie could fix the things
that people here's the thing too if
Jurassic world has taught us anything
it's that Millennials people our age are
ready to see the [__] that they loved as
kids remade reheated and reserved to
them all over again so you're not only
going to get the Millennials who love
the first Bas Jam uh as a kid going but
now they're going to take their kids for
a whole new generation of Space Jam it's
a no-brainer why wouldn't you want to
make tons of money and the things that
don't work if you go back and even watch
the G trailer you reference like the
human cast isn't really that into it it
doesn't necessarily like look that great
it's got pacing R like they could fix
all that there's nothing wrong about it
here's the thing this isn't the question
what movie do you want to stop that you
think is going to make a lot of money
I'm not saying Space Jam 2 comes out
it's not going to make any money I'm
sure it'll make some money my problem is
I don't think it'll be a good product
cuz you're going off of original film
that's a horrible product it's not good
film I don't see why would the new one
be able to improve the motivation for
this is money the motivation is not we
have a new story we need to tell
motivation for every sequel is money
that is not always true but you could do
a sequel and tell a good story nobody's
pitching Godfather 4 like what wouldn't
be motivated by money not but I'm saying
is I want the makers of Die Hard hate
money I Lego movie is really good Batman
Lego Movie I hear is really good you can
make a smart kids movie that's funny and
stand the test of time with a product
like Batman or like I try to pitch
Spider-Man but with Looney Tunes they've
done a horrible job already here's the
thing Michael Jordan arguably that came
out of left field like that guy had very
little Charisma like why is he acting in
the movie LeBron James we like you said
plays multiple roles and he had more
than just a minor part he was an
absolute great actual part of that movie
I want to move over to die hard now I
was about to say die hard I want to move
over to die hard because here's the
reason why I there's two reasons why I
think this Die Hard could actually be
pretty good one Bruce Willis has come
out in interview said he thinks it's a
great idea I haven't heard Bruce Willis
excited about anything in years the fact
that he actually think this could be a
good idea with the bookin means he might
actually show up and play in this thing
it means he doesn't have to do the whole
thing the other thing that I think could
make this great is that the reason that
these Die Hard movies have gotten so off
track is because they keep getting
bigger and more ridiculous you take it
back to the beginning you already pair
down the stakes we don't go bigger cuz
you can't get bigger Die Hard In Space
now we're going back to when he's a beac
cop now this is more in the territory of
the John mlan that we already love but
now we can kind of see how all those
facets started to come together for that
first Die Hard movie and let me just say
like the biggest problem with the last
few Die Hard movies was Bruce Willis the
guy that was literally sleepwalking
through the movie you now take him out
of the movie cuz Courtney was killing it
I am not saying I want J Courtney that
is what you just said you said the
problem listen they were both prom with
that movie oh okay soing you're what I'm
saying is you take Bruce Willis out who
is literally he's the franchise he
doesn't really care anymore he's he's
still going to be in this yeah he's
going to book end it he's literally
going to he's going to be in the very
very end clear happen F yeah exactly if
you get a right actor and the right
director behind this I could be excited
about John McAn who did the two best die
hards is now directing again if he came
back to his franchisees I'm going to do
your one from the director of roller
ball from the director of Predator Die
Hard Die Hard with a Vengeance Die Hard
is his baby he created it and I think he
still could make a good Die Hard film if
given the right opportunity and actually
by going back like I agree with you it
could be a little more grounded A Little
More Level if you bring back John McAn
he's the guy that could probably do it
if you get the right talent and a good
actor like Joseph Gord levit did Looper
I thought he did a great job in that
film playing a younger Bruce Wells
that's a great movie and makeup to make
him look I'm not saying you need to get
the makeup that was Looper specifically
but saying you can get a good actor to
play younger Bru W thetically there are
good act I could see yours working I
could see yours definitely working in
fact I want it I can't wait to see
looking forward to your I love those
characters that they inod you guys must
be the only ones the people did not show
up in drones the people did not show up
in this your final thought why your
movies should be off of the others go
ahead quickly okay as I've said before I
think that Ant-Man is a fine character
but he cannot sustain his own movie we
saw that in the box office I think he is
he it was not one of the most like when
you look at something like doctor
strange that was such a weird property
but it came out the gate so strong
Guardians of the Galaxy Ant-Man did not
come off that way so you already have a
character in your repertoire that's a
little bit has handicapped from every
other character you could do a solo
movie and on top of that you stick him
in between two of the most anticipated
comic book movies of all time people are
not going to be as interested Lon uh I
mean that doesn't make any sense it's a
nice break if you put him in between two
of the most sought after comic W all
time people are just going to be more
interested but I mean to go back to die
hard again it's it's a story about an
unlikely guy who's never been in a
scenario like this and now he finds
himself in that's the meat and potatoes
of the entire first movie if you now
give him an action adventure movie that
takes place before it you've stomped all
over that premise and the idea oh
they're going to do some little gritty
uh disconnected from the rest of series
Beat cop like hard Edge movie with him
in New York you know they're not going
to do that they wouldn't call it die
hard if they wanted to do that because
people would be like well this isn't
like a Die Hard movie it's going to be
him getting stuck somewhere and there's
terrorists and he's got to like out with
them and it's just we don't need more of
that we don't need more the same we
don't need more John mlan they've ruined
it they brutalized this franchise it's
time to like take a break and then
totally you think JT um first of all
Ant-Man again I'm really excited for
that sequel I think they the biggest
thing about that film is they
reintroduced new characters I really
enjoy when I saw Civil War twice opening
weekend and every time Paul Rudd came
out of that van the audience literally
cheered they were so happy to see him
because they love that character I [__]
you not they actually cheered when he
came out I was happy just seeing that
character made me so much happier
watching that movie so and again I can't
wait to see how was plays into the
Avengers I do think they need some more
female superheroes I and I just like I
said for that movie Ant-Man is that
relief from all the dark and dreary
stuff for us Billy lost don't wor Billy
lost okay great
um good goodye whatever they call that
movie I think the reason why I don't
want to see a sequel of Space Jam 2 is
because I need the previous film to
Warrant a sequel not just because it
made some money in early 90s because you
put the biggest athlete in the world in
the film and some sort of property which
was put in there lazily it wasn't like
oh there's not great Bugs Bunny jokes or
Daffy it's literally just product
placement and references to other movies
that are popular at the time there's
been three Good Die Hard movies You
could argue the second one's not that
good but I enjoy it uh liy Die Hard look
great compared to uh the last one that
they did but again they're actually
going to go ahead and try to fix it by
taking it back bringing it back to its
roots if you get the right director and
the right actor in that role with a good
script I think it'll be good oh all
right that did actually make it a little
tougher sorry billly you're out uh dman
is my mark forer yeah I mean you even
said yourself Paul rdd is perfect he's
perfect in small doses was my point the
characters per you anyway Ant-Man is
currently ranked 12th out of 14 MCU
movies as far as gross below Thor above
the first Captain America Hulk movies uh
the opening weekend was 13 out of 14 so
Billy right it was one of the slowest
out of the gate right now Avengers
Infinity war is scheduled for May 4th
2018 Ant-Man for July the following
March is Captain Marvel and then
Avengers 4 so there are actually two
movies between the two Avengers movies
uh they were right that Infinity War now
is not going to be split into two at
least by title Justin Lynn was attached
to direct Space Jam 2 last year starring
LeBron James not much updat since that
probably rewatched the first one and
said uh die hard year one was announced
in 2015 but has not really moved forward
since then Bruce Willis called it a
really cool idea I'm very happy about it
and as somebody who saw 50 Shades Darker
last night I would be really happy if 50
Shades Freed got completely wiped off
the because that movie is terrible worse
than the first one so much worse wow y
now I'm kind of excited not in a fun way
not in a fun way this gets lost in the
lore oh God world too much World
building it's like it's like a subpar
it's like if an episode of Empire wrote
an episode of
Empire but not as entertaining yeah
that's amazing good review there you go
I think you just sold a lot of tickets
Dan no I hope not if anything I said
enticed you to go see that movie ignore
it and
don't all right based on the arguments
sorry Billy you were out I mean and you
sort of even were saying he's good I get
you were saying in small doses but
compared to the other two I think you're
you're out uh so it came down between
Space Jam 2 and die hard and man I was
leaning away but then with the final
arguments you did it did help Co there
uh man uh
I gotta say I was leaning with Lon uh
but I didn't get enough passionate JT
then really came with a passionate
closer for me on Space Jam 2 about the
product and then sort of saying well
there were some fun sequels if we went
back so he came back from behind I got
to give it to JT space Jam's horrible I
thought you had it
Lon a little repetitive there Jam a
great great choice yeah I don't know a
great choice I didn't hear enough
hitting their their arguments back uh
Dan what did they say on the poll
let me check the poll sorry so much fact
cheing in that round I got completely
swamped right now 52% say die hard year
one should be killed 39% voting for
Space Jam 2 only 9% behind Ant-Man and
the W you guys will get it on the drive
home you'll it'll my% we're also far
none no look I'm not like it's not my
favorite one I'm looking forward to but
you want to see that you want to lose
that over die hard and Space Jam
too for the purpose for the purpose of
this fight I did no space
was I saw that I was like ah [__] like
yep that's the right uh those are both
very good answers that was a tough one
all right round
four uh here we go I want to see uh your
answers to this one the question is what
mainstream Studio franchise would you
most want to see Quinton Tarantino join
that's right screw original fun
Tarantino movies we're Studio exec he
owes us money we get to put them on any
franchise we want what are we sticking
them on uh we're back to you jte uh this
was a hard question there's a lot of
ones that went in my mind but I ended up
with The Expendables and I'm going to
tell you why first of all Tarantino
loves genre Kill Bill was a love letter
to the martial art films that he grew up
with and he loves him some 70s and 80
action films he even was quoted saying
in a very early draft from go bastards
his dream project would be have Bruce
Willis Arnold Schwarzenegger and sester
St to be in the film now over the
decades it changed to something totally
different and became glorious bastards
that we all know and love but originally
he said he would love to see those three
his three favorite 80s act stars in a
film together so again this guy's going
to come at this project with some love
and I trust nobody more to make a love
letter to 80s action movies then Quinton
Tarantino the guy who literally has this
guy schedules films at New Beverly like
he bought the theater a couple years ago
and it's my go-to place for 80s action
films you want to see some Dolph lundon
films go to New Beverly Cinema because
he owns 35 mm prints of all these films
he literally collects them watches them
and puts them on for the public to go
see so if I'm going to see this I think
Stallone did fine with the first two the
first film the second one was like
they're they're enjoyable films but if
you want to bring it to the next level
bring in Tarantino who knows that joh
better than anybody and loves nothing
more than to write for actors that he
grew up loving the reason why John dto
was in pul fiction because he loved
blowout it was one of his favorite films
a small film but something that he loved
and he could not wait to write for so
for t to write for these guys I think it
would be a home run L uh so I went a
little different way with it I went
alien and I'll tell you why I think uh a
lot of what makes the alien film sort of
tick is it's these sort of blue collar
guys it's space and it's sci-fi and it's
the future but it's also these
communities of like everyday sort of
people and they're on these ships and
they're sort of surviving and it's like
a job like in the first movie they're
almost like they're sort of space
truckers in a way and that's what
Tarantino does so well is go in these
communities and give the dialogue a real
specificity make you really care about
those characters so that when he does
start ratcheting up the tension when
there is an alien on the loose and
people are being killed you really are
invested maybe more so than you are than
in some of the other Alien movies where
a lot of the sort of background
characters are a little bit more
disposable you're going to have these
really well-defined human characters and
that includes villain characters it's
been a long time since we had a a
memorable human villain in an alien
movie that's always the monsters of the
villains but Tarantino would be able to
really do those like whing utani
Executives or other sort of enemy
villain human characters and make them
really fleshed out realiz more like you
know what we're used to seeing in films
like in glorious bastards or D Jango and
lastly what I would say as long as we're
talking about in glorious bastards
Django is more recent films a lot of
what he's doing especially with dialogue
slowly deliberately ratcheting up the
tension I mean so much of Eng glorious
bastards is let's lay the groundwork and
then let this really long scene play out
as these characters sort of wait for the
inevitable like am I going to be found
out is the LIE going to be revealed
what's going to happen next and that's
an alien movie I mean that's what it is
it's it's confined claustrophobic scenes
with all these characters waiting around
for sort of like when is the hit going
to come and where from and Tarantino
would just masterfully realize those
sequences for sort of unbelievable
tension it' be the perfect franchise for
him to finally explore like sort of
sci-fi horror all these genres he's
never kind of gotten to Billy all right
I I think we are kind of at a Crossroads
when it comes to the James Bond
franchise and for something that is
constantly redefining itself I think
quinon Tarantino definitely would have
so much to play with in the James Bond
world I think the things that were kind
of missing from Spectre and maybe the
last couple uh James Bond movies is that
you know the there's no real there's no
wit to James Bond anymore there's he's
so cold he's he's James Bourne at this
point and I think if you can have quinon
Tarantino not only giving these meaty
monologues to these villains which have
kind of been lackluster look we got
Kristoff Walts in the last one and I
can't even remember what his name is
most people are like oh yeah I forgot he
was in that but imagine Quinn Tarantino
writing this meaty dialogue for these
villains giving them these monologues
that truly put them over the top make
them memorable give James Bond some
freaking humor give him some character
give him some wit and on top of that
bring the signature Quinton Tarantino
action and violence and the Spy genre
something that he really hasn't had a
chance to play with yet I think Quinton
Tarantino and James Bond is a home run
all right it's three genres we haven't
seen him tackle so uh I actually like
all three of these so you don't have to
keep selling me tell me why it's more
appealing and fun for him to do than the
other two for one James Bond um every
single James Bond movie has been
directed by Brit I think it's something
I think it's something where they tap
into that culture because they grew up
that way what it matters to me is I just
feel like he doesn't he's like one of
the most American directors there is
that guy is like the qu you're basically
yeah you're basically thank you for
saying that this is a great new way to
rejuvenate James Bond do something a
little different than what we're used to
be see needs to be rejuvenated I think
Sam Mendes made two really great James
Bond films I think he made one pretty
decent James won a great one and good
one and Martin Campbell made probably
the best one also Daniel Craig if he is
still the same Bond I don't see him
using Quint Tarantino dialogue I'm not
going to see any monologues from this
guy I mean Tarantino he just doesn't fit
the way Tarantino writes people he
writes people that have more quippy
lines I mean his stuff is like the
classy gentleman who's uh laying ladies
and laying out bad guys I just don't see
Tarantino style fitting with that
franchise and I don't think he's shown
that he could really uh tackled just
that kind of spy there's nothing really
he hasn't tackled the Spy genre yet
that's exactly I think there's a reason
because I don't think it really fits his
style of film director we've absolutely
seen that he can put over the bad guy in
these monologues take that scene he
knows how to direct like Kristoff Waltz
in the beginning the Glorious B imagine
if you took took it out and put it in a
James Bond movie he builds this tension
within a bond villain making us care
about a bond villain but he can also
give those great Reservoir Dogs like
back and forth lines to not only Bond
but also also Bond supporting characters
like Felix ligher let's make him a great
that's a a character that I think
Tarantino absolutely would have fun with
with Bond girls we know that qu
Tarantino knows how to use women
correctly in these types of movies we're
not going to get a damsel in distress
we're not going to get a bimbo we're
going to get a strong counterpart to
James Bond I think those characters are
two one note for Tarantino right for
well when you talk about you were saying
like oh it's finally like a witty quippy
Bond like we've had that it's Roger
Moore sort of Pierce broen one that
everybody's sick of like these these
Daniel Craig ones resonated with
audience because they were getting away
from they're like oh it's shocking like
one liner Bond doesn't really of clashes
Roy but ever since then with Skyfall I
guess but like with Quantum assis you
have diminishing
returns return Spectre made a shitload
of money yeah Spector likeor not a great
movie Spectre is more like the throwback
bonds you're talking about in fact you
said like even know it's blow here the
thing here's the thing Expendables
doesn't need to be rejuvenated and
redefined alien the one thing that
Quinton Tarantino is definitely not that
alien needs is subtle Quinton Tarantino
with the horror movie is going to be the
least subtle person he does not have the
patience he does not have the
restraint bastards it's all patience
it's like 12 15 minute sequences leading
to the one piece of conflict that
happens the entire movie is building
tension my alien film and
also Scott said a template when he made
the first alien film visually something
that every director after him has kind
of had Tred to match but I would argue
that James Cameron totally took a
different t on next movie the very next
movie the tantino movie you're
describing is going to be closer to what
reallyy Scott made in the first film I
don't see I don't see Tarantino be able
to match thato would not do anything
ponderous and boring like Prometheus
you're right he would take it back to
when the series was you know is not
going to be able to flex his Quinton
Tarantino muscles
alien because not going be exploitation
movies he's done Samurai movies he's
done he's done a variet these are all
his original Creations he's not playing
in someone else's sandbox like alien
that has such a defined aesthetic
quality to it for me Ali about
atmosphere James Bond what could be a
more defined so serialized with so many
different creators and so many
different made James Bond is series made
for people to come and do their Spin and
then get
the question was what film does tan you
want to see him join what franchise
correct I want him to join a franchise
that he absolutely franch that nobody
likes or cares about that that's why he
should do it cuz he's the one guy I
would trust to do it what a waste give
him an Expendable Z this guy you're
you're talking about the guy who direct
episode to CSI because we can have
tarano memorably right dialog if I go to
an Expendable movie JT if I go to
Expendable movie I don't want a big mey
dialogue character that's what makes
Micky monologue in the first one so out
of place like why are you acting in this
movie I just want to see these
Old-Timers shoot and blow [__] up and
Quinton Tarantino is not like we don't
need him in that mieo has the brains to
take this film and take what we love the
reason why expend are Love Letters to
80s action movies and 70s action movies
in some ways is because the people that
go see it recognize things that they
love nobody does that better than is a
one note that was fun and we've seen
that people have already lost interest
in this concept think about how flat
these movies must be if you the world's
greatest Sylvester Sloan are like ah the
second one's all right you
know whatever like if these were even
halfway decent you would be singing
their praises from the rooftops right
now the again the reason why I go to
these movies and I think they're good I
don't think they're great is because of
my love of the films
that is a great franchise that people
are it's still vibrant people are still
interested in they're still excited
about new ones why would you waste
tartino on expend a franch literally
nobody cares about they can't even
muster up another Tarantino would love
it more than anybody else that's going
to go watch that movie yeah but also
love Death Proof and more than anybody
who went to go see that movie and it's
like everybody's least favorite Taran
movie because you're comparing to all
our films which were well that's what
people Expendables but that's what I
want from him don't I don't want him to
go make an N tarano movie in James Bond
world I don't want to make an N taranto
movie in Alien I want to make an expend
movie that's part of you just want him
in a different franchise that's all
you're saying no I Ross really came
alive for me after hearing all that
Tarantino I want him to play to the
genre that he loves more than almost any
other genre oh my God are you saying
that James Bond is a genre that quantino
is like nah that's not really my thing
such a formula it doesn't give him the
freedom an alien isn't are you kidding
me not as much been really alien has
been beaten into the ground God himself
could come down from heaven and I don't
think that he can make alien worthwhile
anymore James Bond is something that
people always want to see they have
their James Bond they have their version
of James Bond whether it's Roger Moore
or Pierce brow or Daniel crank it's time
for someone else to bring a new vision
to it closing arguments that was those
are billies go ahead there are four the
four sort of original quadrilogy before
it got the Predators and Prometheus the
four main Alien movies were all very
Visionary directors all doing really
different things to expand formula now
they didn't all work but the fact is
that that's a template for a new
director to come in and do just like a
Jan or like a David Fincher or like a
James Cameron like Quint turn is a guy
like that with his own vision and his
own ability to sort of carve out this
universe and make it his own really
integrate his style in with alien I mean
I think I already talked about a lot of
the sort of fundamentals of like the
building of tension and the introducing
of the characters why he work in this
spe specific format but it's exactly in
line with those first four movies to do
a fifth one with Quenton Tarantino GT um
I I'm going to go ahead and say I like
if you said Christopher Nolan I'd love
to see what he would do with James Bond
film I think Tarantino just the way he
writes and the way he frames the
composition of his shots just nothing
about any of his Past film screams to me
this is guy that needs to make a James
Bond film same thing goes for alien
alien for me is more about the
atmosphere and the visuals I never went
to Alien movies thinking oh my God what
a great monologue what a great script I
just went for the atmosphere and the
horror and the tension and the Sci-Fi I
don't think that's going to play to
Tarantino's strengths Tarantino knows
80s and 70s action movies better than
almost any human I argue with you on
this planet and it'll be something
different he's not going to go ahead and
make a Tarantino expend movies he's
going to make a movie that The
Expendables is supposed to be that was
supposed to be that you thought you were
going to get for the first three times
and he's going to do it better than
anybody else I can imagine doing it
because Quint Tarantino loves those
movies he loves those actors he says he
wanted to work with them since the day
he's been
directing Dan well Quint Tarantino uh as
came out a couple years ago was famously
lobbying very hard to direct the Casino
Royale reboot that they did he wanted to
direct Pierce broet in that role they
decided to completely redo the franchise
so they did not go with Tarantino for
that job uh quick fact check jte said
that everyone who's ever directed A
James Bond the movie is British Lee Lee
and Martin Campbell are from New Zealand
Roger spottiswood is British Canadian
and LA's favorite Mark forer was born in
West Germany so they're not all British
I'm sorry I should have said no
Americans directed it uh no no Americans
directed movie uh so many people online
Matt lafy says let's see Tarantino
tackle Nolan Dean said he'd like to see
and also Jonathan Peck wanted to see him
direct something within the John Wick
universe that was probably the one that
I saw the most often Megan W says Batman
why I love movies uh says blade great
vampire writing along with great sword
action sequences and Jazzy Goose says
Friday the 13th ad slasher pesti scream
but darker and more violent and I Andy
I'm going to have to do the poll the
poll is literally tied right now between
the top two choices so afterwards we'll
see if one of them ahead yeah this one's
actually tough
um and the closing arguments helped seal
the deal from me uh I think I think yeah
while I love the passion jte I just
think it's sort of a weird wasted
opportunity for him to to continue such
a Cheesy sort of thing I saw sort of
more Visionary fun opportunities with
Bond and alien based on the argument so
it came down between Lon and Billy um
and this was genuinely tough um the
subtle argument of he's
can't really do subtle sord of fair um
uh
but there's just something interesting I
think of the fact that Lon you did a
good job of saying there's a strict
formula to bond which he'd have to sort
of fall into where then you did whether
it was right or wrong Alien films really
do change every time you make one um and
this idea of this building of tens the
ratcheting of the tension and letting
him do that sort of claustrophobic
horror version it's definitely a new
thing we haven't seen him do uh so you
sort of sold me by the end I got to give
Lon the point all right shut out
sh Billy I'll be honest I thought it was
Billy had it and I thought Billy had it
too you did have a good closer so didn't
that wasn't a Pity point you earned that
one I appreciate that and I I would love
to see uh all all
three see it but I just feel like I'd
rather see him try something
different uh let's see if the poll has
settled on a winner oh right now and
this could change at any second 30 37%
say James Bond 36% vote for The
Expendables 27% for aliens so all three
ideas very appealing to our Twitter
they're really not going to like my next
answer either they're really they are
really not going to like my next answer
point out all right here we go this
one's this one's a barn burner oh my God
uh I thought this would be fun with you
three I'm going to need to take a new
identity after this uh yeah you might
but no own it and you're going first am
question five this one comes from uh Ru
moris on Twitter sorry it'll be up there
I hope because I don't know how to say
it anyway the question is what is the
most overrated movie of all
time uh we're going with you uh Lon Andy
what if I told
you that it was The Matrix hear me out
is that your choice uh yes my choice is
the Matrix uh here's the thing about
saying a movie overrated you got to pick
a movie that's truly beloved and the
Matrix is beloved by almost everyone
except me and I now I'm going to get
into why uh it's mainly a movie that is
remembered as for its aesthetic choices
the style the cinematography the effects
and I'm here to tell you except for a
few memorable moments that were
genuinely sort of trailblazing in its
moment they're not that good it's not a
greatl looking movie in fact it's kind
of an ugly movie it has this amazing
opportunity to introduce you to this
future ruined world that machines have
destroyed we've seen that beautifully
done in other movies The Terminator
franchise sort of most memorably and
what is the real world of the Matrix
does anybody even remember it's like a
lot of garbage on the ground there's
some smoke there's some squid looking
kind of monsters it's ugly it's not
memorable and you can tell because if
this was a really memorable looking
world it would be everywhere you would
see toys we would have toys of The
Matrix ships we would have posters in
your house of what the real world looks
like in The Matrix but it's so flat and
uninteresting that nobody even bothers
to collect it and and just the costumes
themselves became sort of a cultural
property but they're boring the whole
movie is just really sort of flat and
doesn't have a lot of inspiration now we
got to move on and talk about the
premise because that's a lot of what
other people remember this may have
seemed great when you were 13 you never
read a philosophy book you hadn't gone
to high school or college yet and and it
seems like it's real deep but once
you've sort of thought about the world
to the point that you're an adult
there's nothing interesting at the
matrix it's basically like Renee day
heart but for 2 hours and it's Lawrence
Fishburn telling you about it instead of
a professor the dialogue is hacky and
cringey and bad they introduce a few
ideas and then repeat them endlessly
until it's dull until it's drilled into
your head and there's not the final
point I'll make for the intro there's
not a single fleshed out
three-dimensional character do you guys
care about Tom Anderson do you care if
Neo and Trinity really fall in love and
make that connection no it's just a
bunch of ideas thrown at you hoping to
get you until the point where they start
shooting and then you won't care anymore
The Matrix is overrated whoo
Billy guys we're in a crisis right now
we are in a Nostalgia crisis and I think
if you trace all the Nostalgia love back
to one movie again this is most
overrated not the worst the most
overrated movie of all time is ET the
Extraterrestrial now this is a at best
at best decent kids movie and it's
basically the the Old Yeller story but
instead of a dog you get this alien that
looks like Yoda [__] a California
raisin and I'm all of a sudden supposed
to be in love with this thing but really
at its core this is Steven Spielberg
trying to manipulate every every emotion
it's like he is sitting next to you with
a gunpoint Edge saying are you crying
yet are you crying yet it is full of
product placement this is a this is one
big long sappy sacarin commercial and I
have no idea why people this is not
culturally significant it's not it's
great every time I say I don't like ET
people say oh man you have no heart I
watched this when I was a kid I was like
I'm going to stop you right there you
loved it when you were a kid I loved
Chef boy Rd when I was a kid but guess
what I've grown up [__] on Chef boy to
call Chef boy r d fine Italian dining is
what people are doing with ET okay uh I
feel like I need to apologize for my
opponents first and foremost uh two of
the best films of their decade let's say
they were ballsy with their choices
where you going B they're wrong but
they're ballsy uh I'm going to go with
to me what is easily the most overrated
film of all time because it's the
highest grossing film of all time and
I'm going with Avatar uh Avatar was a
cool trick that people went and saw on
theaters the problem is there's not a
good story there's not good characters
it was literally a trick that got
tricked everybody to go see this movie
in theaters to experience 3D for the
first time then you know what happened
they got excited they bought it on
Blu-ray they sat down and watched it on
their 42-in TV they said what the hell
why is this the greatest grossing film
of all time because the story is lazy
it's just recycled parts from earlier
films like Dances with Wolves uh I mean
it's just boring you watch it there's
not one character when you watch Avatar
that stays with you you guys have so
many great characters in moment
that it boggles my mind that you would
pick it the Matrix was a milestone film
for not only just like as far as like
action but like special effects that
alone for me earns it a place in some of
the all-time great Sci-Fi Action films
years has some of the most touching
moments in the best John Williams score
he probably has ever done Anders moments
of pure cinematic Joy there's no
cinematic Joy watching avatar on your TV
at home you just see a lot of cool
special effects which honestly in 10
years will be feel pretty dated and
it'll feel like a really bad animated
film like Fern Gully but in CG here's
the thing here's the thing everything
that you just said about Avatar is
everything everybody says about Avatar
to be overrated you need to be put on a
pedestal that nobody can really figure
out why is it on this pedestal I don't
know anybody that puts avatar on any
best of list anywhere yourie is a great
answer of what movie should you only
watch on like a big screen because it's
true that Avatar loses something when
you go to home video but it was pure
cinematic Joy when you saw it on the big
screen an IMAX 3D it was amazing it blew
everybody away people went to see it
eight times like that's what it's not
overrated like people think Avatar is so
great now it's overrated it's rated I'm
not saying Avatar is a worst movie I'm
saying it's an okay movie that got
overblown and overhyped and was
basically just made a lot money because
of the 3D and the the technology nobody
is still talking about Avatar they're
literally making Avatar Land in like
Disney par perect for like should be
made into an interactive land because
the bioluminescent Forest looks cool I
want to go to Star Wars land because I
love the characters and the sets I love
I would go to Harry Potter people a year
are going go Avatar listen if you're
talking Avatar Land is just a bunch of
bright lights and plants go to
Rainforest Cafe if you really want
here's the thing you just said you just
said that Avatar is essentially Fern
Gully dressed up why is nobody saying
that that uh ET is essentially just
Lassie or any boy with a dog Trope just
dressed up as something different with
an alien that looks like a pis pis alien
you asked the question of like what is
significant like why was ET considered
trailblazing and I I'll explain it to
you I'll tell you it's because it's
because somebody explain this it was
taking this very natural lived in group
of kids that didn't seem like Hollywood
kids they didn't seem like actor funny
quippy kids they seem like real kids
they were going through real problems
they were lonely they were picked on at
school their parents were getting
divorced these are real themes and kids
movies didn't used to be that way
so many it was like the Shaggy Dog and
what ET was doing was saying no let's
give you this really realistic kids who
are going through real things in their
life and will give them this genuinely
emotional story to play out and that's
why ETS shouldn't look like slick and
like a great special effect it should
look sort of odd sort of weird he needs
help he needs Elliot that's the whole
story he's a sort of out ofpl ugly kind
of looking character but because he's
really needs Elliot he needs somebody to
take care of him and that's what the
whole story is about and in terms of
like you could see the exact through
line from something like ET to stranger
things to all these sort of properties
that we've since had that do that same
thing of like let's take these kids and
really make you feel like you're part of
that group of kids but here's the thing
with ET first of all et drives me
bonkers because right at the gate this
movie can't follow its own logic ET has
these great powers that work whenever
the script wants his powers to work
really you're telling me you can float
this freaking bike across the moon if
you can't float your ass up to your
spaceship in the first 5 minutes then
what is the point of having telekinesis
she's object do you want a whole prequel
movie where where Dan can we call
botanicus yeah can we
get he's heavy
let here's the thing you guys are using
the the frog DNA and Jurassic Park to
fill in the holes of where this movie
fails because there's absolutely nowhere
in this movie frog DNA there is
absolutely nowhere in this movie where
that makes any look of sense besides the
tone of this movie is really all over
the place it's really dark and
pessimistic and fear-based that adults
are scary and all these people are going
to come take you away but at the same
time it's so sappy unbelievably you
watch Mech and me or something what did
you watch I don't talk about the Matrix
let talk about the mat talk about the
Matrix talk about the Matrix uh first of
all the Matrix was one of the great
twists in the film that I've ever seen
it's up there with a six The Twist where
he literally dies and comes back and
becomes the one
I it was one of the most Stand Up cheer
moments you thought Keana re dies at the
end of The Matrix well listen the movie
was so good that it brought me to the
possibility that he might actually have
died no you you did not I don't believe
you that's just a lot can we can we back
check that D did anybody get to the anim
be like I bet Neo died are you saying
keu can't die in a movie here here's
here not in that movie St John Wick yeah
he can't this point if you see Keana
Reeves in a movie or really a lot of
action movies at the time let's look at
Die Hard let's look at some of the
big action movie Speed you're not you're
going into that movie because you want
Thrills and you want to turn your bra
brain off they took you into this movie
saying we've got guns we got explosions
come in here and then they delivered on
that tenfold by showing you something
you hadn't seen but on top of that they
said but wait a second we can also
deliver you a story that also makes you
think that also makes you question your
real got a lot of you thought a lot
about the matri oh what am I'm in a
simulation you tell me you didn't walk
out of this movie having conversations
with your friends thinking about like
bigger things like oh [__] how do we
know we're not asleep how do we know
we're not plugged into the Matrix right
now hundreds of years old concept The
Matrix didn't make that's the beauty of
it they took hundreds of years old
Concepts that anyone else would be
like and they put them into a movie and
they made them accessible for people in
a way that was stood on the of other
movies and were like Hey we're going to
do this too like Hong Kong action movies
they were just like well what have we
have a scene like that where everybody
runs through a Lobby shooting two guns
at each other and like sort of
philosophy they're like hey let's look
at every 70 sci-fi movie and take some
of those IDE Silent Running has these
ideas in it from like 25 years before
your film was ground had groundbreaking
special effect bullet time and which was
already in a gap at as I nobody had ever
used it to the extent that they had in
the context back in the context that
they used and they make you wait 80
minutes into the movie to get to it 80
minutes of lar Mission standing like
this even though nobody you don't know
what the Matrix is you got to open your
mind Neo you got to free
like
okay another how about we had one of
those monologues but in front of a plain
white background where you can't either
there's nothing even behind how amazing
is that to go what a star contrast what
a way to wake you up to go into this
movie with all this crazy sci-fi we bu
our movie all right Avatar is this
closing arguments yeah just we got we
focused on at we focus on Matrix last
Avatar has made more money than any
other film was nominated for Best
Picture Your films I The Matrix I can
watch today in special effects hold up
great you're remembering it but it looks
really cheesy H they actually use the
cameras they use the technology where
they go wrap around C re still looks
good to this day Avatar will not look
good 10 years from now it will look
sedated it will look bad unless James
Cameron does a special edition Blu-ray
where he puts it through his processor
and redefines all the images it's not
going to look good there's moments is my
closing there are
moments look people went to see that
movie because it was an event they had
to see what this new 3D looking thing
this is not a movie that people are
going to years from now like oh my God
Avatar that's on the best 100 overated
not nobody is putting that movie on a
pedest if movie gets nominated for best
picture and it's not a good movie to me
that is overrated people are not putting
this on the pedestal they went to go see
it because the Curiosity
Factor not the greatest
one of no look we accepted the answer
but they have a point they arguing you
know these they're arguably more fil but
their movies are so damn good that it
makes no sense for them to say that
they're overrated one more one more
thing I got to talk about turns you said
you said it's a bad story but the the
knock on it isn't that the story is bad
it's that the story has been used before
like the pocah story it's pretty similar
to that the Fern Gully story is pretty
similar that doesn't mean it's a bad
story that just means it's an archetypal
story that he's using to tell the sort
of larger he's getting five sequels
because it made that much money watch
watch those sequels they get anywhere
close to that first Avatar movie this
was a
mess Dan before I try and please
attack this guy about ET I wish I could
have let him fight for me just for that
round I wish I could have too my friend
a lot of people wondering what happened
to Billy as a young child see that's the
only thing that people can say they
don't want to listen to anything I have
to say oh I listened to every word you
had to say Billy uh boy that's a that's
an opinion no fan on
um but I'm just here to check the facts
and the fact the whole round is effing
opinions so there's not really much I
can do over here except just stew
silently and wait for the Judgment how
are they stewing online uh they a lot of
people just everybody seems to have a
movie that they think is overrated I'm
seeing Scarface I'm seeing Napoleon
Dynamite I'm seeing some people think
zootopia a lot of people think that
Frozen is very
overr everybody had there's not there
doesn't no one seems to be kind of
coalescing behind one everybody's got a
movie
tell sha Shank Redemption I considered
it consider should have gone there all
right uh I mean this was rough because I
agree with Billy and line in that JT
kind of picked the easier one because
it's the easiest is accepted but they
were going so so I was listening very
closely L and Billy but my God what are
you guys talking about I wanted to hear
sort of an argument that sort of
Justified it and then I was going
leaning with you L because you made this
whole AR argument about how it borrowed
from things uh but then he literally
just told jte that it's okay that his
film borrowed things no the story
story no it was very specific that's
said it was okay with no he said it was
a bad no you didn't you did just do that
okay let it the anyway
uh uh and then the ET argument but I I
was trying to listen and be objective
there but then Alan really hit you back
with the reasons of why it's really a
good film um uh of the realism all the
things you're sort of saying it's dark
it's like kind of is why it's good
because it's more
realistic uh so there were problems with
everybody and I think you know you
picked an okay movie JT like that I
don't think it's beloved like the other
two so most
overrated because we allowed it I got to
give it to jte just based off those
arguments cuz I don't think either Lon
or Billy really gave me a good reason as
to why Matrix or ET are overrated except
for your own personal preference there
are people out there that love Avatar
I'm not you're in and you're in up with
a lead that is a three points over uh so
should we go into witness protection and
Billy I mean I could have dialed so much
more into like some of the greatest
moments from ET and the Matrix we could
have all right let's do it after the
fight U let's get to our speed before we
do Dan Merl do you have those Nature Box
samples over there because like thank
today's sponsor once again NatureBox is
back uh and I want to thank them so much
for doing that again you can go sticker
Doodles
naturebox.com junkies to save 50% off
your first order exclusive to screenies
Fan so go check it out some delicious
snacks you can choose from uh delivered
right to your door we love nature box I
can't wait to have some of those after
the show this is legit delicious I I
want those sticker Doodles dude why did
you leave all this sticker Doodles
stickles take them away from me yeah thr
them up here I'm going to do it for real
nice all right oh yeah these look good
uh all right Nature Box we love you you
you got the code right there
naturebox.com screenjunkies go there
sign up and give him a try all healthy
stuff all right speed round here it is
sorry tiebreaker first they're all on
the same page sorry I'm the poll on that
last one real quick oh yeah what was it
oh the poll was 58% Avatar 24% ET and
18% matrix by by by Logic that means
Matrix is the most open yeah so what
happened to 24% of other people CH all
right I'm going to ask you both would
you like a creative one or a more
straightforward
one dealer's Choice do dealers okay no
preference you pick you pick I'm going
to go with the more straightforward one
we'll save the creative for later here
we go speed round answer quickly
tiebreaker here we
go best movie
dad oh that's tough Clark
Griswald um oh my
God I couldn't even tell you my name
right now
um yeah this is this is
um you have until I finish this cookie
uh
um that's good right Mr Incredible oh
there go got it in there cookies you're
still in wow squeeze that one
out JT I mean that delicious all right
we got Clark versus Mr Incredible law
time starts when you begin speakings
like I mean Clark Roswell is sort of the
ultimate movie dad he's the archetype of
movie dad the whole character is sort of
designed to be like a stand in for John
Hughes dad and sort of represent the
dads of everybody watching like these
memories of going on vacation with your
kids and taking the family out he's so
sympathetic he's so relatable but he's
also kind of a jerk and it's that great
amazing balance of of being sort of we
relate to him and yet we also repulsed
by him all right
Billy I think Clark Griswald is such a
jerk that that makes him not such a
great dad sometimes he is such a goof
that you don't want him as your dad Mr
Incredible he's somebody that you know
cares about his family more than
anything else I think Clark gwal
sometimes cares about himself more than
anything else and I think Mr Incredible
also has the will to protect his family
he's got a just a better family to want
to protect them Clark uh Clark gal's
whole story is about loving his family
protecting him one and came together Mr
Incredible's whole story is about
leaving his family because he's
unfulfilled by them and he has to go
find Adventures outside the house so
your argument is actually the
opposite 10 seconds for
billys are good yeah dude so good it's
like Christmas tastes like Christmas
Clark chrisal absolutely only cares
about himself Mr Incredible cares about
his entire family his kids love him so
much he also can protect them they all
have superpowers he takes them on
adventure that they actually don't suck
and clarkk will take some on shitty
vacations wow a good clothing D I chew
what do you think let me tell you that
was uh that's really difficult um a barn
burer they came back at the end came
back at the end I think that Billy
Unleashed a devastating first round
against laon and it's for me it was
really could lawn fight back against a
really strong first round for
Billy I thought he did when he said they
left the family that was a that was a
good followup it was a good followup but
but I don't know if it was a better
argument than Billy's I I I I think that
Billy got it right at the end of his
last uh part there and I'm I'm going to
side with Billy on the oh you don't get
I can't that's right I forgot we're not
in the speedrun I will say I will said
adus Finch yeah well that didn't matter
I I agree with Dan it was very close lwn
but I got to give Billy the speed round
or the tiebreaking point that means
Billy you're in the final speed round
here with JT I love and that means Lon
you're going to help us decide this
round of applause though for Lon I've
seen Incredibles once on a plane I
remember nothing could not
give all right here we go guys this is
for all the marbles the bragging rights
until we do this again y I can't wait
here we go
uh are you going to let us know if a
choice are open
before okay
who would win in a fight Rocky or Rambo
ramboo JT got Rambo
yep and that means Billy you have
rocky oh I've already won this round
just cuz JT is going to die inside no
matter who wins so moral all right
whenever you're ready JT you're going to
give us
Rambo Rambo is the ultimate killing
machine he's a green bar that was a
Vietnam P he's been tested Rocky is too
nice of a guy he wouldn't see Rambo
coming he would trust him and he would
like shake his hand and be like hey
buddy the Rambo would take him out with
a knife Rambo's a killing machine I mean
he's a Green Beret he's eating billy
goats and doesn't puke he if you're
going to fight Rambo you better bring
some body bags and he has Troutman and
more
weapons Billy when you're
ready the thing with Rambo yes he is a
Green Beret but he's also shown in his
movies that he's a little bit of a loose
Canon you don't know what he's going to
do but Rocky is so disciplined he is a
train fighter all he cares about is
fighting he knows how to win he knows
how to discipline himself to win that
fight and a one-on-one he's absolutely
going to knock out Rambo cuz Rambo's
just going to sit in the corner and cry
about all his life experiences while
Rocky just get
up all right
JT Rambo is not lose Kane when it comes
to war he is a perfect killing machine
Rocky is too nice he's too good of a guy
Rambo actually has has weapons knives
artillery he could stab you with a piece
of wood and shape
it I'm going to say shape piece of wood
I said it backwards I meant shap piece
of
wood Rocky's a boxer he's got the
endurance I think he could run circles
around Rambo before Rambo could ever
even touch him he's going to hit him
with the knockout punch and then if I
want if I want to take Rambo paintball
gun sure he'd win that but a fight a
straight fight
no it is who would win in a fight uh Lon
let's go to you first based on those
arguments uh Billy Billy had the tougher
Billy was behind to begin with uh I
think he did a pretty good job of
fighting back but I I still have to say
yeah Rambo in War I I think he Rambo's
going to take it so I go with J very
close the question is do I think Rocky's
going to be around long enough to get
that punch in and I think maybe jte made
the case that he wouldn't be it's close
but I gotta say with jte yeah I think
you had a shot it wasn't an impossible
feat but yeah uh JT just clocked you
with too hard with all the Arsenal so he
was ready to go so JT gets that point I
might or might not have been arguing
that fight my whole
life all right here we go ready mhm
since you all work on the
show what's the best speed round
question we've ever
asked oh God can be TV fights or movie
fights I got to try to remember some of
the movie the best speed ask a question
before I answer yeah Best in terms of
like most creative or just the best
fight that came from it uh best Crea
question I'm trying to remember some of
the
questions um it's really I don't
remember I I would have had an unfair
Advantage also fact check I don't work
on movie fights you do TV fights he said
you could do a TV I can't do TV fights
well then JT watches them all I know I'm
just trying oh okay I've I've got mine
on on TV fights we said who would you
rather share a bath uh bathtub with
Trump or
Negan all right JT got give us are we
going for creativity here or yeah I'll
take anything at this point I'm just
trying to I'm trying to remember if a
speed round um can you not think of lot
yeah I'm thinking hold on I'm thinking
of a good one all you have until I
finish this cookie
okay the new barometer love these Nature
Box Cookies who would win in a fight
alien or Predator that's one from my
fight I did ask that that was I I fought
that one okay you got one in
good alien or predator and uh Trump Oran
in a bathtub okay go ahead Billy when
you're
read man I know how to F
this I think I think Predator versus
Alien is a very generic question no
offense but I think it's something that
everybody asked Trump versus Negan in a
bathtub that's going to stir up some
controversy and if I do believe so jte
actually won that point so he knows it's
a great question because it actually got
him the victory of the game it's funny
it's topical it's a it's something that
starts a conversation Predator versus
Alien and we've had that conversation
[Music]
how dare all right ready here we go Al
vers Predator is a Timeless question
something that's been asked since the '
80s and when of the two greatest horror
movie villains of all time in sci-fi
your question is the moment is a
question of the moment of the time 10
years from now no one's going to care
about that question Negan is going to be
afterthought something that failed to
live up to the comics whereas predator
and alien are something that will stand
the test of time in cinema history and
it's got to be vers PR it's there's so
many
variables 10 seconds
I think when you ultimately do a best of
screen junkie show my speed round is
going to end up in that show because
it's funny it got such a great response
yours is too generic to ever make a clip
show because it's just like any other
speedrun this channel is called screen
junkies for movie fans they don't want
to talk about Trump or Negan they want
to talk about films and they want to
talk about two of the greatest icons of
horror and Cinema ever and not to
mention they have two different fighting
styles so that you have really T the TV
was allowed bro that was a very
fascinating fight I how do you ARG that
I got to give Billy though a props cuz I
do think he when he said what's going to
make the movie fights
real that is that's a very that's an
Insider win that I think uh put Ed me
over the sort of obvious fight but I'm
curious Lon and Dan where you were
standing uh I mean it's a little tough
because I wrote one of the two question
being deated so obviously I think the
alien Predator question is dynamite but
uh I will say uh even though he was
trashing my uh work I think Billy had a
lot of great points and and uh I do
think that the Trump Negan question is
very clever so I would probably throw it
to Billy doesn't matter what Dan thinks
but you can go ahead and say something I
don't really get that round at all so I
agree with you too all right that was
tough that was I don't know how to argue
that all right here we go Billy St
you're still you're still in this Billy
is in a must-win situation on every
question you guys ready
mhm are we ready yeah y y y hold on let
me get up there who would you rather be
in a hot tub with Negan or Trump Trump
trump that's not the real
question please dear God let that be the
question that's the question uh I fought
this already I fought this already so
you got so you got Negan I got n he got
Trump and uh JT got
Trump can I be
excused here we go is that who you
fought last time fought last won and you
picked the one he knew he' win you
picked the other person a weird Choice
I'm not really thinking right now I'm
just doing I'm like the Joker I just do
things I'm I'm doing what the script
says I'm trusting Max on this one we
both thought it was funny here we go
he's first uh yes you were first uh
Billy [__] my life um I got lots of
ideas he you have the
sorry when JT won that argument I don't
believe Trump was yet president so now
that we know that he's president uh
nobody's going to show up to this thing
they didn't show up to his inauguration
Negan has to have women in this bathtub
because he's going to force them to be
there it's going to be a party by force
nobody wants to party with Trump
nobody's going to party with Trump ever
they've shown that they don't want to
party with Trump I definitely want to
okay JT
okay got quite few uh originally I said
I'd want to be a trump because he
probably has a huge thing in Trump house
now I actually get to go to the White
House there's no other time I'm ever
going to be able to go to the White
House so this is my chance also Negan
you're probably in some Warehouse with a
rusty tub you'll probably cut yourself
and then he might kill you afterwards
just for fun at least Trump I'm in with
bodyguards I get to go into Lincoln
office I can't it's my own personal trip
to the White House how can you pass that
up 10 seconds
Milly JT you fool he doesn't even live
in the White House he's going to be in
New York the whole time you're never
going to the White House at least my guy
I trust Negan with the baseball bat more
than I trust Donald Trump anywhere
within
me 10 seconds GT
I would never trust Negan that's the one
thing you learn from walking do never
trust Negan Trump at least he has all
the eyes on him he can only make so many
mistakes plus I get to go to Trump Plaza
I'm hanging out with his kids I get to
hit on his sister on his
daughter okay yeah you get to hit on
aanka aanka is that who you meant
Tiffany aanka okay uh the G end on these
question based on the answers Lon well
uht points we saying the Lincoln
office office L Office Lincoln bedroom
yeah I'm sure Lincoln did have an office
in there but it's not the name of a say
both that's why I need to go to the
White House lawn I need to learn these
things it's an education right um wow I
don't want to get into a TB with either
of these guys but uh I don't know I I'm
tempted to go with Negan because yeah
like Trump it's a really it's going to
be depressing it's going to be empty
he's going to be angry Negan is going to
have a bunch of people there cuz he
forces them they're scared of
I thought JT had it with the whole White
House thing but then when you mention
the whole well you're not going to go to
stuck in stuck in Trump Tower sort of
was a nice even blow Dan where are you
going I know I I it's been a lifelong
drink of mine to visit the Lincoln
office I thought that was a great angle
I thought Billy had a great comeback but
it was a comeback to what I thought was
a really good argument and a really good
uh way to spin the question and I I have
to decide with jte the only way to go
I'm going to White House jte
wins
what a way to lose this game go out on
bathing with nean blame that producer so
now JT is twice a trump supporter just
for the
recordt fun uh well jte you earn the
bragging riots how do you feel I feel
really good I was worried like those
weren't exactly movies questions so I
thinking myself oh I God Billy I know
more movies but I really had to get on
my toes there we had to make you really
ear aell F uh well we'll talk more and
after the fight I'm excited to JT at JT
movie thinks else yeah check out my
YouTube channel where I do like reviews
trailer reactions uh everywhere sown
screen junkies right here I'm all over
the place everybody love it laon Harris
at l l NS that's me Lans uh yeah follow
me on Twitter I'm on a bunch of SJ Plus
shows I pop up from time to time so uh
stay subscribed good job dude thank you
Billy Patterson Billy a Patterson yep
you can find me every Tuesday in the Dan
Merl spot for TV fights gentlemen
honored to have been here with you had a
great time yeah this just fun yeah uh
Dan Merl Merl Dan on Twitter Merl Dan
what a fight this was as we discussed on
sju yesterday I'm sorry Billy lawn
you're both
fired J congratulations I regret nothing
uh no that was fun that was energetic I
hope uh I hope everyone enjoyed watching
it at home as as much as we enjoyed it
here in the room it's a good time yes
they those stream cared I love it thanks
for bringing it as always and thanks for
your fabulous work here gentlemen
couldn't do what we do without you guys
so glad we got to Showcase your movie
expertise here for all of you to see uh
and thank you all at home for watching
tune Us in next week or tune Us in on
screen.com for the after the fight right
now
bye-bye thanks to NatureBox for
sponsoring this episode for more
information click the link in the
description and right now you'll save
even more because nature boox is
offering screen Junkies 50% off your
first order when you go to naturebox.com
green
junkies again that's naturebox.com green
junkies for 50% off your first
[Music]
order